the world outside of central Maine
almost never got to know Stephen King if
not for his wife's diligence and their
confidence in her husband the book that
launched a million pages might never
have come into being when his wife
Tabitha rescued the start of the
manuscript of Carrie from the trash and
insisted her husband finish it King was
working as an English teacher and
writing on the side Tabitha's judgment
was absolutely right Carrie was a smash
hit and Stephen King is now one of the
world's most famous and prolific authors
so what's the story behind the stories
well let's dive into his life
Stephen King was born in Portland Maine
the largest city of the mostly rural
state that services the setting for so
many of his famous stories Stephen was
the second son born to Nellie and Donald
King but the family of four soon became
a family of three when Stephen was only
two years old and his brother only for
their father went out telling the family
he was buying a pack of cigarettes and
he never returned Kings mother worked
several jobs moving with the boys from
Maine and going from state to state to
find work and a place that she could
afford to live and raise her two boys
but Maine it was home and it's where the
family eventually settled for good when
the family moved back to Maine they
didn't have indoor plumbing and this was
the 1960s
king's life growing up it was a far cry
from the wealth that he has now but King
didn't see his childhood as exceptional
or out of the ordinary though he does
acknowledge he's always liked scary
things
my childhood was pretty ordinary except
from a very early age I wanted to be
scared I just did I was scared afterward
I wanted a light on because I was scared
there was something in the closet my
imagination was very active even at a
young age some have said the king might
also be inspired to write such
horrifying stories by a childhood event
he doesn't even remember according to
mum I had gone off to play at a
neighbor's house a house that was near a
railroad line about an hour after I left
I came back she said as wide as a ghost
I would not speak for the rest of the
day I would not tell her why I'd not
waited to be picked up or phones that I
wanted to come home I would not tell her
why chums mum hadn't walked me back but
it allowed me to come alone it turns out
that the kid I had been playing with had
been run over by a freight train while
playing on or crossing the tracks years
later my mother told me they'd picked up
the pieces in a wicker basket as
traumatic as that event must have been
it was not the only explanation for
Kings at vivid imagination
friends of the Kings tell stories about
how the family was well known for their
attention to literature if their mother
couldn't find or afford a babysitter
should leave her sons alone with the
expectation they would read aloud to
each other Kings love of stories and the
written word was fostered from an early
age and of a tradition it's stuck
King and his wife Tabitha also made
their own children read aloud to each
other and to them he'd even record them
on cassettes to make the family
their own collection of audiobooks
growing up King also rent material for
his brothers newsletter called Dave's
rag
they made copies on a mimeograph machine
and distributed it to their friends but
King was seen able to move me on just
writing for his siblings newsletter in
1965 when he was still in high school
King was published in comics review the
story was right in line with the
frightening plots that we all know King
for today King had been working as a
gravedigger and money as a teenager the
job in Spartan to write a story called I
was a teenage grave robber and its
publication was his first taste of
published success the only downside was
that he didn't get paid for the work his
first paid publication didn't come until
he was in college and he earns $35 for a
story called
the glass floor King graduated from
Lisbon falls high school the high school
in the town that later became the
setting for portions of the book
11/22/63 Lisbon Falls was a mill town
and King spent time working in the
town's mill when he was a teenager
after graduation King had aspirations to
be a writer so he headed north to the
University of Maine Orono
to earn a degree in English literature
while in college King was a columnist
for the college paper was outspoken
against the Vietnam War and worked in
the college library that same library is
now home to many of Kings papers it's
also where he met his wife Tabitha was
looking for a book in the stacks and
King passed by and struck up a
conversation with her and four years
later the literary couple had graduated
had a daughter and they were married
voguing had been writing in college he
was far from being able to support
himself and a growing family just by
writing he Tabitha and their daughter
Naomi were living in a trailer outside
of Bangor and King was working two jobs
he was teaching English at Hampton
Academy and in the summers was pumping
gas at the local station while also
working shifts at a laundromat
Tabitha took shifts at a Dunkin Donuts
and they struggled to get by but King
always made time to write even in the
cramped quarters of the family's trailer
he made a point to set aside space for a
writing desk and a typewriter 2,000
words a day was his goal and that's a
goal that he stands by today
eventually King earned teaching
certificates and was able to put his
college education to use as a teacher at
Hampton Academy the work still wasn't
what he wanted to be doing though it was
writing that he loved and writing that
he wanted to earn a living from writing
simply has always been his purpose in
life as he explains there was nothing
else I was made to do I was made to
write stories and I love to write
stories that's why I do it I really
can't imagine doing anything else and I
can't imagine not doing what I do though
it took years of effort his big break
did come after tabatha fished the
beginning of carry out of the trash in
1973 King finished the book and sent it
off to a publisher he wasn't confident
about its chances of being published
saying my considered opinion was that I
had written the world's all-time loser
the family wasn't doing well financially
when he sent carrion and they couldn't
even afford a phone so he got the news
via telegram he'd be receiving a $2,500
advance and Doubleday would be
publishing Carrie then even better news
came the paperback rights were sold for
hundred thousand dollars and with that
king could quit teaching and begin
writing full-time and his family would
be better off than they had ever dared
to imagine the book it was an absolute
smash hit within the next year a million
copies were sold and only three years
later it was made into an Academy Award
winning movie Stephen King was now
officially a writer and an American
celebrity but success did not mean the
king settled into a completely
untroubled life as he kept writing
cranking out books like misery and Pet
Sematary he was drinking heavily and he
knew he had a problem King later told
Rolling Stone nobody in the house drank
but me my wife would have a glass of
wine and that was all so I went into the
garage one night in the trash can that
was set aside for beer cans was full to
the top it had been empty the week
before I was drinking like a case of
beer a night and I thought I'm an
alcoholic
that was probably 78 79 I thought I've
got to be really careful because if
somebody says you're drinking too much
you have to quit I won't be able to he
knew he had a problem but he didn't stop
drinking in fact he took it one step
further in the late 70s King started
doing cocaine using it at night while he
was writing by this time he and Tabitha
had three kids and he knew his
addictions were taking a toll both on
his family and on his writing he
attributes the length of Tommyknockers
to cocaine and looking back as said the
book could have been half the length if
so much of it had have been inspired
purely by his drugged up energy he has
also said that he doesn't even remember
writing Cujo so bad was his consumption
of alcohol and drugs during the 80s he
said there's one novel who joked that I
barely remember writing at all I don't
say that with pride or shame only with a
vague sense of sorrow loss I like that
book I wish I could remember enjoying
the good parts as they put them down on
the page indeed The Shining and misery
both carry an undercurrent of his
reference to his struggles Jack Torrance
is an alcoholic in the shining and King
has describes the antagonist of misery
as essentially the personification of
cocaine it wasn't until the late 80s
when tabatha threatened to leave him and
the family staged a dramatic
intervention that King cleaned up his
act at the intervention his family
displayed drug paraphernalia rent pills
that they had collected from the trash
gang with the magnitude of his problem
laid out in front of his eyes and in
front of his family and friends made the
decision to get sober
now he's been sober for nearly three
decades during the 1990s and into the
21st century King continued to be one of
the world's most prolific and well-known
writers his book spawned movies and
miniseries and over 350 million copies
of his books have been sold after he
became so popular King took the step of
publishing under a pseudonym Richard
Bachman he wanted to see if he could
still get books published and have them
sell without his now-famous name
splashed across the front turns out well
he totally could the first book he
published under the name Richard Bachman
was range set in Kings familiar world of
Maine High School the book tells the
story of a teenager who engages in
violent acts at his school he sets his
locker on fire shoots his algebra
teacher and attacks another students
with a wrench in 1977 it was a figment
of Kings imagination but in the late 80s
and 1990s the book
unfortunately started to resemble actual
occurrences at schools across the United
States in 1997 after a student shot
eight people at a prayer meeting in
Kentucky it was discovered that he had a
copy of rage in his locker disturbed by
this King asked his publisher to take
the book out of print to this day rage
remains out of print
even as his success grew King remains
living in Maine the family owns a home
in Bangor and a home in Louisville near
the lakes for the summer it was never
home in Louisville that King's life
almost ended in 1999 King was taking a
walk along one of the winding wooded
roads that are so familiar a part of
Maine's landscape then a van smashed
into him from behind
King was knocked off the roads and into
a ditch witnesses said he was in a heap
and it was clear his leg was broken his
glasses flew off and landed in the van
that hit him at the hospital he
underwent multiple surgeries and had to
do physical therapy as a part of his
recovery Bryan Smith the driver who hit
King had a track record of driving
infractions including a DUI the King
accident was blamed on Smith his dog
distracting him causing him to swerve
into the author Smith received a
six-month jail sentence that was later
suspended and had his license revoked
for a year King was pretty upset at this
he wanted Smith's license revoked for
life given his history of bad driving
only a year after the accident Smith was
found dead in his trailer at the age of
43 he died of a painkiller overdose and
in the twist of fate that seemed
straight out of a king novel he died on
King's birthday September the 21st King
sustained horrific injuries in the
accident but resumed writing only a
month after being released from the
hospital
he finished the highly regarded on
writing and in 2000 the book was
published but by 2002 King decided that
he simply didn't have the strength to
keep writing as he had in the past where
he had previously sat in typed for hours
at a time it now hurt him to sit for
long periods addiction had also become a
part of his life again after the
accident he took oxycontin to deal with
the pain from his injuries and he became
addicted to it as he had the decade
earlier he was able to overcome the
addiction and to live life once again
soberly but the lure of the written word
and it ultimately proved too strong for
his post accident injuries and struggles
and so King returned to his craft he is
said that he literally needs to write in
order to live and what would happen if
he didn't write oh I'd be dead I would
have drunk myself to death or drugged
myself to death or committed suicide or
some goddamn thing well since his
accident he's published dozens of
stories and books including mr. Mercedes
do Mackey
11/22/63 and under the dome a diehard
Red Sox fan like so many of his New
England neighbors Stephen King also
co-wrote a book after the Red Sox 2004
World Series win faithful to diehard
Boston Red Sox fans Chronicle the
historic 2004 season shared the story of
the emotional roller coaster King and so
many other Red Sox fans rode throughout
the summer and fall of 2004 in a further
display of his eclectic interests and
abilities King demelza music he played
guitar for The Rock Bottom Remainders
Ave and use other members you might
recognize - Amy tan Dave Barry and Matt
Groening are only a few of the other
celebrities who join King on stage even
actually co-wrote a musical with John
Mellencamp billed as a Southern gothic
supernatural musical ghost brothers of
darkened County opens and ran for a
month at the Alliance Theatre in Atlanta
King is now 70 years old but he hasn't
run out of ideas in fact he and his son
Owen just released a co-written book in
King
well he's incredibly wealthy he writes
and sells books at a breathtaking pace
but he doesn't use his wealth to amass
stuff in Tabitha owned three houses - in
Maine and one in Florida it's the house
in Maine that is the most iconic located
in Bangor it's a huge old Victorian
surrounded by a wrought iron fence
decorated with bats from the outside the
house is exactly where one would expect
Stephen King to live on the inside it
has an indoor swimming pool and a huge
underground library the houses are
extravagant by everyday standards but
they really are the primary way King
prefers to spend money on himself and
Tabitha I'm not too close this person
I'm not a boat person we do have a house
in Florida but we live in Maine for
Christ's sake it's not like a trendy
community or anything his houses are
beautiful but they don't use all of his
money so well what does he do with it
all well he gives it away mostly more he
invested in projects that support his
interests and his community a music fan
King has also purchased radio stations
in Maine a huge baseball fan he funded
the construction of a Little League
field in Bangor the field is now known
as the field of screens a tip of the hat
to the fields Thunder together he and
Tabitha run the Steven and Tabitha King
foundation libraries and colleges
especially the University of Maine and
the Bangor Public Library have benefited
from Kings philanthropy Maine's
Historical Society's fire departments
arts organizations and hospitals have
also been beneficiaries of the Kings in
a 2001 speech at Vassar College King
made his view on generosity and charity
clear to his audience should you give
away what you have of course you should
I want you to consider making your lives
one long gift to others and why not all
you have is on loan anyway all you want
to get at the gettin place from the
Maserati you may dream about the
retirement fund some broker will try to
sell you on none of that is real all
that lasts is what you pass on the rest
is smoke and mirrors in that same speech
he discussed Natural Resources and his
dislike of the George W Bush
administration with the advent of
Twitter in the years to follow King has
an even wider audience to share his
political views with he's taken on
president Trump our Twitter announcing
that the president wasn't allowed to see
the new version of it when it hit
theaters in 2017 he's also made clear in
very profane language and we
repeated here what he thinks of the
president and his administration Stephen
King is a national figure in his own
right
for 30 years he's been affecting the
conversation around pop culture his
books sell by the millions and his
movies rake in millions of dollars and
win Academy Awards growing up he knew he
wanted to write but he never wanted to
do it to achieve the wealth and fame
he's now amassed his reasoning is much
simpler and it remains his mantra to
this day writing isn't about making
money getting famous getting dates
getting laid or making friends in the
end it's about enriching the lives of
those who will read your work and
enriching your own life as well for over
three decades from his home tucked away
in the northeast corner of the United
States Stephen King has been able to
live out his childhood dream to write
for a living in doing so he's brought
many of us nightmares but their
nightmares the world gladly welcomes as
we continue to delve into his stories so
I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and do not
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
just like this every day of the week
also over there on the right check out
some of our stuff from the archives are
the great people that you might want to
watch biographies of and as always thank
you for watching